un peu de légèreté pour terminer ce
journal avec une première aujourd'hui à
marseille le crazy horse organisé un
casting comprenait une audition serge
dupuis chez bernard thébault ont suivi
une des candidates
j'ai vu j'ai dans vue des auditions
paraître sur le journal et
et bon je veux dire j'aimerais
j'aimerais beaucoup y rentrer j'aimerais
beaucoup y rentrer c'est c'est
impressionnant quand il s'agit du crazy
horse je pense je veux dire pour une
danseuse c'est c'est très bien c'est un
bon départ ça amène beaucoup de choses
on peut connaître des gens ça peut être
bien
et après quelques minutes de danse sur
fond de jazz sur les six candidates une
seule est retenue et ce n'est pas
sandrine à cause de sa morphologie
envoyé alors né suis pas déçu ah oui
d'ici la prochaine fois c'est pas grave
cet instant il faut il faut subir des
échecs de temps en temps cette chose
réussir et pourtant selon le boss de la
revue ici on a souvent l'élégance de la
danse
elles ont une allure est long
sur de comportement sans ambition aucune
et elles sont donc là mon avis jouer au
spectacle et à la danse d'ailleurs on a
eu beaucoup de danseuses qui venait de
l'open marseille la jeune fille que vous
avez déjà après sélection bien d'abord
des grandes fermes et 2,71 à wemmel là
elle est fine
elle a un corps de danseuse très musclé
mais l'ennui c'est qu'elle est beaucoup
trop jeune elle a à peine 16 ans donc
nous on n'engage jamais des danseuses
avant 18 ans pas de chance donc pour
sandrine mais un espoir pour erika de
devenir un jour à kadhafi ou foxy
labrune marseillaise deux des 24
danseuses de ce music hall parisien